Hello Kelly.
First of all, a very big
thank you
for accepting to do
this little interview.
Thanks to you.
Can you tell us
about yourself
and what you're working on?
All right, yes.
Thank you very much, Liliane.
I am Kelly Picard, I am French,
a lecturer at the University Jean-Monnet,
near Lyon, in public law.
I work more specifically in public law.
I've been working
for about ten years now
on the notions of historical prejudice
and transitional justice.
We will go back to this later.
Specifically, I dedicated
my PhD thesis to these questions,
namely, the question of
the responsibility of the State
in the reparation
of historical damage.
In addition,
my research mainly deals
with the protection
of rights and freedoms,
mechanisms of justice
and reparation
in post-conflict situations,
typically, Truth
and Reconciliation Commissions,
and the different forms of reparation
considered in such contexts,
which somewhat fall
outside the typical legal framework.
I also had the opportunity
to go into the field
in order to assess the theories
that I had developed during my research,
particularly for the Central African context
in Bangui, in the Central African Republic,
where I was able to participate
in the process of reconstruction of the State,
or at least in the post-conflict period
in recent years.
There it is.
Thank you.
To get straight
to the core of this topic,
you said that you are working
on historical prejudice.
Can you tell us exactly what it is,
what you mean by that?
Yes, of course.
The first thing you need to know
about historical prejudice
is that it doesn't actually
exist legally.
So this is already a first obstacle.
It doesn't exist, so it was
my concern to conceptualize it
because even though legally,
it doesn't exist,
the social impacts
that can be experienced
through historical prejudice
are very present
and therefore I found it necessary
to conceptualize the idea.
So, what do I mean
by historical prejudice?
Broadly speaking,
it is the idea of a situation
of extreme violence,
whether it is extreme
in its gravity
or in its mass character.
Extreme violence
that has not found a response
in terms of justice or reparation.
Therefore, over time,
the State has not provided
a satisfactory
or sufficient response in terms of justice,
so justice in the broad sense,
that includes precisely these questions
of reparation, truth, and so on.
This has created a feeling
of resentment, frustration,
anger, a certain form
of animosity, even mistrust,
which is transmitted
from generation to generation
and which,
as we have observed,
is also reinforced
from generation to generation,
until it potentially explodes
like a sleeping bomb.
Françoise Sironi,
who is a psychologist,
talks about the sleeping
bomb in society
when we do not
take seriously
these phenomena of violence
which are very serious
and which we prefer to dismiss,
to put under the carpet
in order to get rid of them,
saying: "Let's move forward.
The past is in the past, etc."
These social phenomena...
So, my concern
was to try to give
a concrete and legal reality
to this phenomenon and to try
to have it taken into account
in court
so that we can finally
bring a response
in terms of reparation and justice
to the people who were
in fact doubly victimized,
because they were victims
at the time of the violence,
victims of abuse,
typically everything that is
a crime against humanity,
genocide, war crimes,
therefore serious violence.
Then, they are doubly
victimized
by being denied
their status as victims
and never recognized as such,
and when the State never
recognizes their suffering
and the prejudices
they have experienced and suffered.
So, this reinforces once again
this feeling of injustice,
a double injustice both in the State
that has allowed the violence
to take place,
and also in the State that has not
brought justice for this violence.
This is what I mean
by historical prejudice.
Thank you very much.
Therefore, do the crimes
of colonization
and the crimes of slavery
fit into this category
or since
the crimes of slavery
have been considered
as crimes
against humanity,
is it no longer necessary
to use this category?
So, I include the crimes
of colonization and slavery
in this category
of historical prejudice
because there is indeed this double dimension
through historical prejudice.
Why historical?
Because there is this double
phenomenon in terms of history.
There is history in the sense
that there has been a punctual event,
a historical event
that has generated a prejudice.
Then there are the historical facts
in time, diffuse, latent,
which create
this historical dimension.
In this double meaning,
namely old prejudices
such as colonization
or slavery, could fit
into this category.
Then, if we enter
into purely legal
and technical questions,
we have the questions
of prescriptions,
of the interest to act
which will come into question
and will constitute obstacles
to legal actions.
Perhaps we will
come back to this later,
but typically
both colonization and slavery
constitute historical prejudices
to the extent that
they were characterized
by extremely serious violence.
In the French case,
for example, colonial
slavery or the Algerian war
did not receive a sufficient
or satisfactory response
in terms of justice.
So we would typically
approach these situations.
To make sure we understand well,
what do we actually gain by using
this category of historical prejudice
rather than crimes
against humanity?
Good question.
The point is...
Actually...
So I'm just thinking about it,
so I don't say anything foolish.
The idea of historical prejudice,
which is also underlying,
is the idea of a prejudice
that is transgenerational.
This is a little bit
the idea that I defend
and which is a little bit
complicated for lawyers
to conceive
in a very Cartesian mind.
It is the idea that, in fact,
this violence, this phenomenon,
the war crime
or crime against humanity,
did not only have
repercussions on the people
who were present
at the time of this violence,
but it also had repercussions
on the descendants of these people,
the descendants
of these direct victims.
There were phenomena...
When we study
psychology or sociology,
or even now
neuroscience,
there is more and more
research that tends to show
that there is
a transmission of trauma,
sometimes even
in the genetic heritage
or in the psychological heritage.
There really is a form
of transmission of traumas,
injustices,
repercussions over time.
Therefore, the idea also through...
The idea of historical prejudices
would be to recognize
also the potential effects
on all the successive generations
and to understand better,
the society as it is today
and the social phenomena today.
In fact, transgenerational prejudices
tend to be taken into account
and considered a little more.
Some lawyers
before the International Criminal Court
are trying
to focus on the question
of transgenerational harm,
because it is specifically in the Katanga case -
if I'm not wrong-
concerning
the Democratic Republic of Congo.
The Court agreed
to recognize...
So it was a question
of crimes against humanity, war crimes.
The Court agreed
to recognize transgenerational harm.
So the fact that the descendants,
the children of people
who experienced these wars, these attacks,
these events have suffered damage,
psychological consequences,
sometimes physical consequences.
We could elaborate,
but there is also a whole...
The field of study
that I also like
in these questions
is the case of Rwanda, because in fact,
the effects of war rapes,
at least on future generations,
are particularly evocative
because women
have contracted diseases,
women who have given birth to children
as a result of these rapes.
Thus, the effects
on the generations to come
are particularly serious
and striking.
We can observe them very well.
The fact remains, and I return
to the International Criminal Court,
it recognized these prejudices.
It did not deny them,
it recognized them,
but refused to repair them.
It was considered
that the causal link
couldn't be proved.
It was difficult to really
prove that the pathologies
that young children suffer today,
the psychological disorders, and so on,
were directly
and certainly attributable
to the fact that their parents
had suffered this violence.
So, it is the causal link that was somewhat lacking,
but we are making progress,
step by step.
So, just to answer your question
in one sentence,
because I took a few
detours, the difference
with crime against humanity
is that for crimes against humanity
we only take into consideration
the direct victims,
therefore, the first rank of victims
who are concerned by this violence.
The idea would be
to see the global picture
and all the repercussions
on society,
because massive violence
such as war
and crimes against humanity
do not only have repercussions
on the people who
have experienced these phenomena.
In my opinion, it has repercussions and disruptions,
like a big ripple effect.
Great, it's crystal clear.
Thank you, perfect.
And so, from there, do we...
So, let's imagine
that we manage
to go before a...
Well, I don't know if it would be
before a national jurisdiction
or an international jurisdiction,
would it be possible
to have the responsibility
of a State like France recognized
in the context of the crimes
committed in the former colonies?
Yes.
So, apparently a simple question,
but a very complex one.
There are many things.
There are many things because
there is at the same time
the question of responsibility.
We'll talk about the
responsibility of the State,
but I'll come back to that.
Then, there is also the question :
before which jurisdiction?
Yes, indeed, there is
national or international.
Just a word
on the responsibilities,
it is true that here,
I focused
on the idea of a responsibility
of the State,
to seek a responsibility of a State
because one can also
seek the responsibility
of individuals, individually,
meaning private individuals,
citizens or physical persons,
but who are representatives
of the public authority,
like a mayor
or a president of the Republic.
It seems to me
that this does not fit
with the idea
of historical prejudice
because it is a succession
of responsibilities.
There is not one person
responsible for all of this.
It's a chain
of responsibilities.
There is this idea
of historical continuity
and everyone has
their share of responsibility.
So, it bothers me...
Well, it's not that
it bothered me.
It's just that
these mechanisms
that make individuals accountable
for their actions,
already exist.
So what I wanted
to explore a little bit is:
can we hold a State accountable?
This is already
a little more complicated
because from
a penal point of view,
it is not possible.
It is not possible to engage
the criminal responsibility of a State,
because in the criminal field,
there is this idea of moral element.
In fact, there is the idea of intention.
To hold, for example,
accountable an individual
for a genocide,
it is necessary to prove
before a judge
that this individual had the intention
to exterminate a population.
Now, in fact, this contradicts
the principle of a State,
since it is not a person
who is thinking as such,
so one cannot prove
the intention of a State legally,
even tough one could question it.
However, in the current context,
criminal responsibility and the State
are not compatible.
Therefore, these are public responsibilities.
Thus, public means
the whole State community,
all the State institutions.
Yes?
Just a quick question, can the criminal liability
of a company be...
The criminal liability
of a company?
Good question.
This is a bit out of
my field of expertise.
It can be...
I'm afraid I might be
getting ahead of myself.
Yes, we can cut that part out.
No, no, there's no problem.
Maybe it's possible.
Maybe it's possible,
but I have a little doubt.
Then, there's always the difference
between private and public,
and a company is private, so...
In fact, as soon
as you are in public law,
the State always
has derogatory rules.
So, even though
there are things
that are possible
in private law,
they are not always possible
in public law.
I admit that I prefer not
saying anything wrong.
Okay.
I don't want to make
a statement.
To come back
to the public question,
which is the collective
responsibility of the State.
At this point, therefore,
it is possible,
indeed, to activate
the responsibility of the State,
both internally, nationally,
and internationally.
Both cases or possible.
On the internal level,
what we have, in France,
are mechanisms of liability
for faults or without fault.
Both are possible.
So if it is for a fault, there is
an aggravating factor.
This is what we call
administrative law.
Then, there is
the international level
where we have
for example, go before
the European Court
of Human Rights, before...
So, eventually, the United Nations
Human Rights Committee,
but it is not a jurisdiction
as such.
The United Nations
Human Rights Committee
makes recommendations,
but it does not have
a binding action for sanctions.
So, it's a little bit limited
in its effectiveness...
However,
there are possibilities.
It should be noted that earlier
I was talking about the ICC,
the International Criminal Court.
This is a court that is
only competent
to address individual responsibilities.
So, not States,
but individuals
are prosecuted before the ICC.
So, if we were
to prosecute
the colonial crimes of France,
what would be possible?
I mean, I guess
it depends a little bit
on where the crimes
were committed
and whether we act
at the national,
regional or international level?
Yes, then indeed,
we have several options
even if they are not all...
I am an optimist
by nature, but I must admit
that I am skeptical.
In any case,
at the international level,
if we start
we don't have
many levers of action
because
we may have
the United Nations
Human Rights Committee,
but as I said, it essentially
makes recommendations.
So there are not necessarily
any binding means.
Apart from that, we have
the European Court of Human Rights,
but Algeria is not a member
of the European Council,
so that would imply
a Franco-French action,
even if it could be initiated
by activists, by associations
or by descendants of victims,
it is quite possible.
Moreover, there is at the moment,
and the decision will be announced soon.
An action before
the European Court of Human Rights
concerning the reparation
of French colonial slavery.
On the basis of this famous law,
the Taubira law of 2001,
which recognizes colonial slavery
as a crime against humanity.
It is actually a group,
the Mouvement International pour les Réparations
(International Movement for Reparations),
a collective, that has initiated
legal actions in France
to demand reparations
because, in fact,
they have underlined the fact
that a penal qualification
has been established,
that it has been recognized
that there was a crime against humanity,
but that this has not been accompanied
by any reparations,
which is peculiar because it has been
established that there is a crime,
but no repairs have been made.
Thus, they took
legal action
before the French courts.
Each time, they have been rejected
and so they have reached
the European Court
of Human Rights,
where they are trying
to defend their case.
We will see what the Court will say,
even if, well, generally,
it is not very daring
on this kind of sensitive issue.
However, it could be a way
to try to get some leverage,
to put some diplomatic
pressure on.
Therefore, we'll see
what happens.
We need to point out
another issue.
It is the temporal competence
of these courts.
In fact, all these
international jurisdictions
are quite recent
and, for example,
the European Court of Human Rights,
France only ratified the statute,
so it only accepted
the jurisdiction
of the Court in 1974.
This means that everything
that happened before 1974,
cannot be considered by the Court.
If we take the case of the ICC,
the International Criminal Court,
came into force in 2002.
The same thing applies
to all the facts prior to 2002,
which the Court
cannot determine.
Therefore, we have
a real problem
with the question
of the Algerian war.
It happened a long time ago,
and thus, the competence
of the courts is limited.
Hence my bias, I actually
try to go through
the back door
of transgenerational prejudices
and to recognize the fact that,
even if the facts are old,
the repercussions
on individuals
are still present
and these actions
still have consequences.
Therefore, there are still prejudices
today that are suffered,
but it is a little difficult
to get the courts to recognize it.
There is this barrier,
that is temporal,
which means that
there is no way around it.
There is no retroactive application.
A court cannot take up
facts that took place
before it was created.
That is a real problem.
On the other hand,
there is the possibility of creating
institutions that are
somewhat specialized,
like we did, for example,
for the International Criminal Tribunal
for the former Yugoslavia
or for Rwanda,
creating specific jurisdictions
that will deal with past events,
but they will be created for this purpose,
but this also requires
a certain international consensus
and a political will to create them.
So that's at the international level.
At the national level,
there is still the possibility
of referring to the domestic courts.
We are also left with a somewhat
Franco-French question.
Finally, there is not this...
Although there is not
this idea
that would be important
of cooperation
between Algeria and France.
So, we remain...
Well, these are
the current debates.
We approach the subject
a little from our French perspective.
However, it can be a way
to move things forward
in terms of reparation.
The difficulty is to find
the right legal basis,
to justify the prejudice
and the causal link.
In fact, for liability,
three things must be demonstrated.
You have to show
a causal event.
You have to show a prejudice
and a causal link
between the event
and the prejudice
and often the difficult part
it is to show the 100 %
causality between the two.
That's where
the courts rush in
to dismiss this type of litigation
and once again,
sweep it under the carpet.
So, if I understand you
correctly,
the alternative would be
to try to mobilize
as much as possible this category
of historical prejudice.
That would be the alternative?
Well, yes,
but I'm preaching
to my choir here,
but of course
that's how I approached it.
After that, there is
everything that is...
In fact, when I worked
on these questions for my thesis,
I was quickly confronted...
I considered
all the possible mechanisms
of responsibility.
I saw that even if each time,
there is a small step missing
to be able to get there,
these are obstacles
and as I said,
well the lawyers, they are straightforward,
Cartesian, so all these things
and the fact that
there are repercussions
on the bodies and the minds
of the generations after,
it is something that is
going to take a little bit
of time to process.
So, there is another possibility,
which is not to resort
to the legal route at all,
that is to say that we must
ask ourselves the question :
what do we want?
If what we want is
a form of reparation,
but that maybe translates
into official public recognition,
into public policies,
whatever they may be,
whether it is a bit
of positive discrimination,
whether it is access
to care,
whether it is compensation.
In reality, you don't necessarily need
to use the legal system,
and that is why I looked into
transitional justice,
because it actually is
the essence of transitional justice.
It is a justice that faced
with the obstacles of its environment
and the rigidity of the law,
will work around it,
use various ways and set up
paralegal systems
that borrow a little bit
from the ceremonial of justice,
but that fit next to
and in parallel
with institutional justice.
Hence, typically,
the Truth and Reconciliation Commissions,
like those made
in South Africa or elsewhere.
There is also an option
that is quite interesting to explore,
and which is starting
to come up quite a bit,
which is what we call
courts of opinion.
Tribunals of opinion
have been set up, for example,
in the field of environmental law.
The Monsanto tribunal is
actually a court of opinion.
So, given that
environmental law was not
sufficiently developed,
we still do not have a consensus
on the crime of ecocide,
and so on,
well, a simulation
of the tribunal is made.
We recreate all the ceremonial
of a court with experts,
public figures, and we pretend
to judge the facts in question.
This was also done
for what concerns the comfort women
during the Second World War,
these Korean women
who were used
by Japan to satisfy
the needs of Japanese soldiers.
Faced with the reluctance
of the justice system to recognize the fate
of these women,
they set up
courts of opinion.
So, in fact, they acted
as if they had judged the perpetrators,
whether they were individuals or states,
the Emperor in this case,
according to rules of justice,
either borrowing
from existing law
or inventing them
to show how the law
should evolve, and in fact,
this has this effect, afterward,
of diplomatic, political and symbolic
pressure that is also very strong.
So, there are other avenues
that can go beyond
what exists and the jurisdictional
and institutional side,
that is sometimes very rigid
and not flexible enough
to understand these situations
that are a bit
outside the legal category.
Last question, quickly:
did these courts of opinion
make it possible
to change the lines?
Yes, but courts
have very slowly
moved the lines
regarding the comfort
women, for example.
They have progressively...
well, it's been decades,
but they are beginning
to get some kind of recognition
from Japanese institutions,
but it's still very limited.
But anyhow, there is also
an international awareness
on these questions.
This is also the goal,
to shed light
on these issues so that
others can take them up
and the movement can grow.
As for Monsanto, for example,
in environmental law,
where there have been
more concrete repercussions
and because there are also
environmental issues,
it is a little more consensual
and it is a little easier
perhaps to bring them,
but there are a whole lot of...
There are a lot of court
of opinion experiences
of which I don't know
well enough the repercussions
afterward to know if
it has been systematically
followed up.
But it's also...
This remains in fact the limit of the law,
even institutional law,
it is subject to political will
and therefore, even if
we have a classic legal decision
or a legal decision
that is a little
more simulated
according to processes
that are a little more innovative,
well, if the political power
does not want to follow,
does not want
to enforce these decisions,
it remains difficult to impose it,
as they remain in control of its own realm.
So, it remains quite difficult
to move the lines
and time is
a powerful ally
in these mechanisms,
but to make
one last small parallel,
with regard
to the Second World War,
at the beginning, individual responsibilities,
therefore, of the perpetrators,
were recognized.
For example,
with the Nuremberg tribunals,
perpetrators were condemned.
However, to recognize the collective
and global responsibility of the State,
we had to wait,
in the case of France,
until 2009, for a first
court decision in France
to recognize
the responsibility of France
in the deportation
of the Jews of France.
So, 60 years,
when it came to the Holocaust,
and so time, really,
is an important element,
even if it never goes fast enough.
I can understand that,
but when you look at it,
it's almost the same timeframe
with the Algerian war,
it almost ended 60 years ago.
So, we are perhaps
in this pivotal moment.
That's why we feel
that things are starting to move.
Maybe it's those 60 years.
There is perhaps
a generational element here,
which means that
it begins to emerge
and that we can perhaps hope
that it will move a little more.
Very good, that's great.
Listen, I'm looking forward
to the discussion that we can have
with both activists and students
on these subjects.
Yes, I hope it can shed
a little bit of light
and give some food for thought.
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Thank you Liliane!